all right you guys know I love robots
and you know I love dogs so I was able
to combine robots and dogs into a great
story Google is making a robot dog
they're working with Boston Dynamics and
they've created a robot dog named spot
and let's take a look at the videotape
all right I'm impressed with spot but
naturally first why are they kicking
spot why was that dog if it was right
you would not be kicking that dog and if
they were there people will be up in
arms Peter would be protet why are we
kick I'm glad I'm glad you brought that
because I thought I was gonna be the
only one it's a piece of machinery right
I still feel bad for the dog yeah you
know what can we throw the video up for
one because you're right there's
something so innate skittering and the
big kick was worthless yeah flipped on
the ice yeah watch that next kick and
that guy's kicking it with a certain
degree of so what does that say what
does that just say before we really get
to it cuz I felt the exact same thing if
that had been something that looked more
like a spider or some other amorphous
robot you wouldn't have felt it but
because it looks like a dog we all felt
that we have empathy for these sort of
you know artificial creations which is
either going to save or doom the human
race we do these robots when will the
robots take over because that's where
this all leads right robotic cars we're
walking around with our devices the dogs
you're gonna kick a dog I mean it's
gonna bite your head off I mean when
what year I want a year I keep asking
people I'm taking a poll when do the
robots take over completely take over
completely take over 2065 Wow that's
late it's late you're sure there's
enough people who are worried about it
already early enough there's gonna be
some safeguards they're gonna last us an
extra 20 years ah all right I like that
oh yeah I mean I'll give you the 20 but
let's say twenty thirty seven twenty
thirty seven yeah yeah I think that's a
little more in line
with what I'm thinking do you because
you're your kid who is look at
everything on the screens that that's
not gonna stop exactly do you think that
robot dogs could ever actually replace
dog dogs I mean there there would be
actual functional reasons why having a
robot dog would be good you could go on
vacation you have to worry about feeding
the dog or walking it or blah blah blah
well there's a lot of you guys know I'm
gonna compare it to like the classic car
situation because I'm a gearhead the
old-school only I mean people who soup
up newer Hondas and Acuras I'm like
that's not a car dude like you know old
Chevy's 1970s 1960s 50s a little too far
back
but like cars had carburetors you know
and engines that you could hear leaded
gasoline
yeah good ad-lib do you think I had a
car that had to ad-lib so that doesn't
seem safe so the thing is when so with
this there's gonna be the original
people who like I have a dog that
breathes in he's food you have this new
dog that can run forever but he doesn't
breathe sleep so there's gonna be the
hierarchy and some people's mindset I
have a real dog but you have the fake
one
they'll be bright and then do we get to
the point where so then everyone
suddenly has robot dogs but then only
rich people can get actual dogs then we
combine them into robotic animal dogs
that's a little island of dr. Moreau I
think there are people who have dogs for
practical work reasons you know they're
they're shepherding or they're hunting
or they're you know something I think
most people have dogs for the affection
you know for the actual interaction with
the living thing so I don't know that
people you know I can't see like old
folks homes getting a robot dog cuz
that's gonna make the the people who
live there feel any better you know I
think I think there's gonna be a dog
with a brain and a heart is gonna still
have a place for a lot of people I think
but they that's what'll be eventually of
course these look like obviously
machines I think it's gonna be the point
where you like we're saying is that a
real one or is that the robot dog
it can only cuz it's gonna stop making
the the noise of yeah it's gonna stop
yeah all this is gonna change and you
know maybe the backwards bending legs
will be the giveaway yeah why are you
kicking robotic dogs people
there's no reason to take a robot dog I
get it the dog can move it's just
necessary anyway what do you guys think
you want robotic dogs how about clone
dogs let us know in the comments right
now